i'm curious since you and i have always
been very candid with each other
we we we have real talk on this program
and i i really enjoy that because a lot
of people don't like to talk about race
you know especially when it's
when you're different than each other
right it's a hard thing for people to
talk about these days on twitter but you
and i always have productive discussions
so i was curious i wanted to ask you a
question that i'll just cut to the chase
you know you got rejected a lot you talk
about it in your new book it's about
damn time
which i have just started listening to
um
and it's great by the way really thank
you you do a great job also
um i don't know if you stop talking do
you do you read the whole thing
oh yeah oh yeah okay because i'm only
like two or three chapters in and some
people tell me
it's on me some people read the first
two chapters and stop and you know you
go through in the book
you know exactly how hard it was for you
to break in but
all your different techniques were
breaking in um
but let's face it like not everybody
wanted you
in here not everybody gave you the
support and now we see all these
protests
and twitter is a virtue signaling
like machine with all these white vcs
non you know
underestimated founders and
i'm curious if your phone is ringing off
the hook now where people are like you
know what i should have backed you
before and i kind of [ __ ] that up and
now i need to back you now
so have the during these protests you
get all this white guilt and people
saying
i gotta make up for this and they call
you as the
the route to get to this deal flow yeah
it's happening the things the last few
weeks have been very very interesting
uh i've been watching it unfold when it
comes to people
reaching out a lot of scrambling going
on
there's a lot that was the word i was
looking for yeah yeah
it's going on there's also a lot of
sincerity um in my opinion come
go going on where some people who who
have been in the past wanting to work
with us but didn't have the power within
their organizations to do so
are now they have more leverage
internally now to say look
you you all have we have a problem i
know where to go
and that reaching out so there's it's a
lot of that inbound
and sussing out what is um worth our
time what is valuable what is worth the
founder's time and what is not
because i i just don't play the game of
like
holding out the buckets and just taking
any money that will will fall
that's just not interesting to me um the
autonomy
i think you you're talking about how we
have a lot in common i
like to talk more about that too if you
don't mind too yeah i think it's
interesting
um but that autonomy is really important
and that integrity is really important
to me and to our team
and so we are we are highly protective
of our
company the companies that we've
invested in that have allowed us to
invest in them and we're highly
protective of our of our own
brand and integrity and reputation most
importantly and so
yeah it's coming out of the woodworks
you know people are just all of a sudden
so woke and so oh
i knew it all the time and i felt this
all the way but every once in a while
you'd get something sincere that is
worth taking a look at
you know even on a cynical approach
where it's like oh my god you
you know it's so hard for people to say
all black you know black lives matter
right and when i first heard the term
black lives matter i was like well
everybody's life matters right like
that was my initial reaction too and
then
because it's and it's like a i think a
very
interesting test to at what point
you realize that all when people say
black lives matters
they're not saying all they matter more
than other lives
right that they have been they have not
mattered
and all we're asking for is to catch up
and make the matter as the
as much as anybody else's i will freely
admit
i had the same reaction but to hold on
to that reaction now
after you get through the mental
exercise of saying what is the person's
point in saying
black lives matter oh their point is not
to exclude everybody else
it's to let you know that they're just
trying to reach up to have it
to for parity right yes 100
100 and people are getting there
and i think you could be cynic one could
be cynical and i would understand you
especially being cynical about it
having you know knocked on doors and
gotten turned away
but in another way hey late to the party
fine but you're here at least we have to
you know
um get you on board so that maybe you
will have a black partner in your you
know partnership or you will
syndicate a founder from a black deal
you know who's a black founder a person
of color an underestimated founder
yeah i'm i'm not here to to to be
anybody's savior to kind of
make them feel like they've caught up
i i'm definitely someone who
you have to start you start with 100
with me you have to lose points
you don't start at less than 100. you
know what i mean like you have to
you and so i'm a fair person and i'm a
person who feels like i feel like
what are we fighting for if not for us
all figuring
getting it getting it and working
together at the same time
as rihanna says you know don't mistake
my kindness for weakness
there are it there is a difference
between someone
getting it and then really getting it
and then saying oh i've not got it
before
but now i want to be part of this and
i'm going to go back to the people
i know are working on it and talk to
them how do i help
and someone who is like oh i don't want
to look bad
or i don't want to lose these other
resources that are um
dependent on me look like being in this
in this field uh so i'm gonna i'm gonna
claw my way
or you know there's the group that's
just doing these these crumbs
these little you know it doesn't take
anything for them to to
to it falls out of their pockets as
they're standing out of the car you know
to me that's insulting and it it's not
that i will never get to
you i i agree with you and i like you
and and i think you're doing a good job
but it's just that a lot of them are not
there yet
and that's okay to say too
you